Sau khi trải nghiệp e-tay tài Việt Nam, các viên thoại Premium League đã phải thuốc lên
e-tay Việt Nam hiện tại Y-Chóo.
Tên D-Seringham, Quai Choc, West Brown, đi on đúc lên, những cái tên tưởng chiến ở Premium League đã để
bệnh viện tâm anh để trải nghiệp hệ thông chân thiết bị e-tay hiện đại không cám gì Chóo.
Đông thời kiểm tra dây chăm, phục hồi vui bằng rô bốt và hẹt tổn thiết bị hiện đại bật nhất hiện nay.
Và họ không dấu được bất ngờ, quà?
Đi phíao lai ziu dục.
Tên D-Seringham, chia sẻ, tôi rất tưởng khi ngày tại Việt Nam đã có bị vệ đầu tư như mấy móc hiện đại,
hỗ trợ cả những cầu tủ chuyên nghiệp.
Giang tủ West Brown, hảo ngứng và ấn tượng với các chăng thiết bị e-tay đặc biệt là các mấy móc uống dụng ở 2.
Chúng tôi chưa có gì thấy các hệ thông mấy móc này tại anh.
Sất thu viện, tôi chưa tưởng được chánh nghiệp ở anh.
Giang tủ West Brown nói, không chỉ nơi bật mời phán tham mộ cùng nghiệp bóng nát.
Bình Nam giờ có một chung tâm được sĩ chân tương tể thao.
Thái khóc, phục hồi chức năng khiến các cựa dành tủ đến tưởng nước anh phải chăm châu.
Tựa sơ mài c dì một chăm nghìn lắt cắt, em rai ba tên xong trình đoạn hình anh, đến vừa bốt
một tình kinh sọn náu một đất phay sinh app thịt thông đồ bốt ra phay cí ít ai giúp mộ hơn
một trong 2.5 li vức tạc.
Hãy đồ bốt lượng ra dây chẳng đen lắc, tiếp bị dờ phó phục hồi khu trọng lực.
Đến kiến thật thái khóc không cắt cơ, lỗi soi ít sâm lấn, phục hồi chức năng,
đều quan trọng làm bỏ phí chính đu dự dựa được cá nhân hóa, phù hồ phía trạng,
một tiêu vẫn đồng và mức độ tổn thương của tương vừa bệnh.
Có lẽ chính vì sự đồ tư trọng thế bị ý tế hiện đại, đừng uống chuyên gia bác sĩ giòn,
dưới phụ tốt, mà không ý việc kiểu người nước ngoài tử ốc,
miếng, châu Âu đại trọn Việt Nam, cho mình vệ tâm anh để thay khóc, mộ dưới trạng,
phục hồi xò trình thương tế vì năm viện dành ở nước ngoài.
Vi ở tâm anh, người bệnh có thể mù, phục hồi và suyệt trở về nước trong bòng chưa đến một tình.
Tại bệnh vị tâm anh không phải trên tương nào của cân lột.
Bây nhiên trên tương như đứa xe trạng bản phần, bác sĩ sẽ yêu tiên phục hồi bảo tôn,
không so kéo, giữ lại tối đa cầu chúc tự nhiên, nếu cần cán thiệp, có thể lựa trọn lựa soi tệ tạng bằng gân tự thân,
gân nhìn tạo. Học bè, ký thật lựa soi xe học xuống xe trạng tự lành bằng cầu lối xe học đặc biệt,
không cần thay tòa mộ. Bởi các cá thay khớp, ký thật không cách cơ giúp mề bệnh đi lại chỉ xong một đến 2 ngày.
Ngoài ra, có cả hơn 2 bệnh mục phẫu thật trong ngày, mùa vào về chỉ xong khoảng 2 viーフーニn lời,
không cần làm việc ở bệnh vị tâm anh, dù bạn là cầu thủ chuyện về phai nhân viên phần phòng,
tất cả điều đựa chuyện như một vấn đấu viên đăng trên đường trở lại xinh cò, phục hồi nhang, toàn dịch, đúng trình cú tế.